Musik
Ja, hallo. Hallo, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast-Ufo. Setzt euch rein, kommt rein, macht die Tür bitte hinter euch zu. Macht's euch gemütlich, macht's euch locker. Wir sind heute das Gemütlichkeits-Ufo. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Aber bitte die Tür, wie gesagt, zumachen, weil letztens haben sich Leute beschwert, dass draußen dann immer noch ein bisschen zu laut ist, wenn wir hier die Tür... Und wegen der Pollen, wisst ihr ja. Wir haben ja einige aller Allergiker unter uns, deswegen wollen wir hier mal ein bisschen Rücksicht nehmen. Stefan ist auch mit dabei, der hat die Schuhe schon ausgezogen, die Socken auch schon halb. Da hinten Nina, bitte die Schuhe auch. Und die Tür, wieder, nochmal, also aus. Wie gesagt, lass dir einfach zu. Tür aus, Schuhe zu. Florentin ist, sorry, ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt. Florentin ist auch da, hallo, herzlich willkommen Florentin.
Will. Ich habe schon genießt eine Menge, ich habe schon eine Menge genießt dieser Tage, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe nämlich einen Riesenfehler gemacht, ich war draußen, du hast davon abgeraten, du hast versucht, mich davon abzuhalten, ich habe nicht auf dich gehört, ich möchte mich entschuldigen, dafür deinen Rat abgeschlagen zu haben, ich war unterwegs und ich glaube, ich bin der unsouveränste Outdoor-Guy der Welt, ich glaube, Seven vs. Wild bestünde aus einem Supercut aus mir. Mit deinen Augen immer mehr zusammenschwillen und am Ende selbst deine Schwellungen und Schwellungen haben und irgendwann so anfängt, einfach so, was dann wiederum für Forscher ganz spannend wäre, die Allergie würde dann sozusagen dein Gehirn wie so ein Parasit, so Facehugger-mäßig, übernehmen und dann anfangen zu sprechen.
So Bewohner der Erde.
Und dann kommt so, alle Ergologen werden dann sehr interessiert, was da passiert.
Was verlangt ihr von uns Menschen?
Weg mit den Erdnüssen, weg mit den Pollen und mit den Erdnüssen.
Alle Buchen müssen weg, alle Buchen? Was ist, wenn Allergien, jetzt ist ein spannender Vorschlag für die Fiktion auch da unter euch, was ist, wenn die Allergie ein Testmechanismus von Aliens sind und erst wenn wir Pollen und Erdnüsse und Sonne, Sonnenallergie und Haustaub losgeworden sind, dann kommen die Aliens. Also die pflanzen die Allergien bei uns ein und testen immer so, die hören mal rein und hören Ja, die hören noch 100 Jahre. In 100 Jahren gucken wir wieder rein und erst wenn sämtliche Hunde, Katzen, das sind die Tiere, die sie am meisten hassen, selbst wenn wir die eliminiert haben, dann landen sie. Das ist meine These. Allergiethese eins. Ja, viele andere
Thesen haben wir nicht. Wir können ja einfach mal probieren,
alles was ausrattet. Das ist eins der
großen Rätsel der Menschheit ist,
wie entstehen, wie zum Teufel, das glaube ich auch
in das Paper heißt so, wie zum Teufel,
was zum Teufel sind diese Allergien?
Und woher kommen sie? Warum gibt es manche Dinge, gegen die niemand
allergisch ist? Niemand ist allergisch gegen Enten.
Was ist das an Enten? Bei mir ist es, ich habe
damals einen Allergietest gemacht, mit diesem witzigen Käsekästchen, Karo, Tattoo quasi, war mein erstes Tattoo auf den Unterarm und dann werden da so Salzsäure, Heroin gespritzt, halt so verschiedene Sachen und dann guckt man so und dann war wirklich so, wie so Schiffe versenken. Oh, sie vertragen Zyankali nicht. Das ist ja komisch. Und dann schaut er dann so an und meint dann so, ja, okay.
Also wirklich, zwei waren so gerötet, ganz klar abtrennbar.
Das ist Hausstaub, das ist Buche.
Na und, also da haben wir dann noch, also das ist jetzt nicht die medizinische Lehrmeinung,
aber es gibt ein Feld, das, wie gesagt, das wird so nicht gelehrt,
aber man geht davon aus, dass das für das Übernatürliche steht.
Und es kann gut sein, dass sie allergisch sind gegen spektrale Erscheinungen, Widergänger, solche Wehrwölfe.
Alles was kommt, wenn man nach dem Satz, oh das EMF spielt verrückt.
Ja genau, das heisst, immer wenn ich jetzt unterwegs unterwegs bin und nimmst du so EMF mit? Weiß ich nicht, ist das jetzt eine Buche oder ein Geist? Und es ist natürlich Wie niesst du? Mach nochmal nach. Das ist dein Nieser. Es sind zwei Töne, es ist eine ganz scharfe Terz. Es ist eine ganz, ganz klar und es sind auch immer genau die Töne. Und eher, wenn ich das schreiben müsste, Hennne! Es sind zwei Töne, es ist eine ganz scharfe Terz. Hänne! Es sind auch immer genau die Töne. Und eher, wenn ich das schreiben müsste, Hänne. Hänne, ja. Wohingegen meint es eher Boucher wäre. Okay. Boucher! Hänne! Haben wir alle schon verstanden. Aber nie nur einer, nie nur einer, immer mehrere. Also es ist wirklich ein ganz klassischer Rhythmus. Aber auch hier die Frage, magst du das Gefühl nicht auch ein bisschen? Ich habe ja das Gefühl, da werden einfach Glückshormone ausgeschüttet. Ja, das kann gut sein. Man mag das schon gern. Man niest dann eher noch mal. Es gibt ja zwei Nies-Situationen. Einmal die luxuriöse Nies-Situation mit reichlich Taschentücher. Und dann gibt es natürlich die Not-Nies-Situation. Man darf eigentlich nicht. Ruhe abzeilen. In der wirklich plötzlich dieses eine, entweder das oder halt Theater, wo du halt eine oder du hast noch dieses eine Fetzen Taschentuch und das ist plötzlich der wertvollste Stoff der Welt.
Einfach so, du würdest vierstellig ausgeben für eine weitere Packung Taschentücher, aber du musst die Zugfahrt nach Ulm noch schaffen, Toiletten, kein Papier mehr da, alles ist weg und du hast noch dieses eine Fetzen, wo so noch diese letzte Ecke, so dieses Gallien, Gallien hat sich noch befreit von dem Einfluss der Römer, ist noch trocken, der Rest ist schon verbraucht und du weißt, ich habe noch zwei Nieser und dann ist Schluss und das ist dann wirklich anstrengend, da macht es dann keinen Spaß. Und dann der Gedanke an Opa und Oma, die ja immer dieses eine Papiertaschentuch hatten und die auch irgendwie achtzig geworden sind,
wenn man sich denkt, ja gut, ich werde es jetzt noch mal benutzen können, oder? Ich werde es noch mal benutzen können mit einem altes Taschentuchlein. Im Grunde schon und tatsächlich, also ich bin nicht stolz darauf, aber in solchen Momenten der absoluten Not denkt man ja wirklich auch einfach schlicht pragmatisch an Lösungsansätze und man überlegt, wie kann ich denn das benutzte Taschentuch einfach wieder trocknen? Also kann ich das jetzt nicht, also ICE innen an die Scheibe oder so, dass es sonder sein wird. Im Grunde ein Handtuch ist ja auch einfach nur trocken, nass, trocken, nass. Ist wie eine weiche Scheibe. Ja. Du könntest einfach gegen die Scheibe. Ich dachte, da wolltest du jetzt hingehen. Ja, nee, da wollte ich gar nicht. Okay. Ich wollte nur, es gibt ja kein dreckiges Handtuch, es gibt ja nur nass und trocken und das ist immer ein Hin und Her. Und so ist ja eigentlich ein Taschentuch, könnte man ein Taschentuch ja auch sehen. Okay. Du willst nicht gegen die ICE-Scheibe niesen? Nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Du willst lieber, okay. Nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Ich habe gerade gedacht, unvergessen natürlich, ich glaube es ist aus dem Film Brothers Bloom, wo ein Allergietest so ausfällt, dass wirklich jedes Feld knallrot ist, weswegen die Person immer drinnen sein musste. Ihr Leben lang war sie eingesperrt, hat glücklicherweise in so einem grossen Anwesen gelebt und hat dann alle Hobbys der Welt erlernt. Kam dann aber raus, dass sie einfach nur gegen dieses Gitter allergisch war. Das ist der Kugelschreiber. Oder gegen den Kugelschreiber. Ich glaube, es war das Gitter, was aufgelegt wurde, gegen das war sie allergisch und deswegen musste sie drinnen bleiben. Ich fand es aber damals schon eine sehr lustige Beschreibung für eine Figur, die einfach Pech hatte und deswegen drinnen bleiben musste. Ja, die so aus dem Raster fällt, dass sie kein normales Leben, gegen das allergisch ist, gegen das niemand allergisch ist. Die so aus dem Raster fällt, dass sie gegen das Raster allergisch ist. Ja. Es ist eine schöne Metapher. Ja, ich weiß nur noch nicht wofür. Das sollen ja die Leser dann, also du schreibst es ja ins Buch und die Leser sollen ja dann sich das mit Leben füllen. Aber Theater ist auch eine schlechte Situation. Ich war auch mal mit so Kumpel von einem Kumpel, so diese merkwürdige Art Mensch, die du erstmal reinlässt in dein Haus, aber ohne Grundlage. Die du skeptisch beäugst erstmal. Ja genau. Wo gebest du hin? Was sind deine geflogen? Händen sie die Schuhe aus? Eigentlich ist es ein Fremder. Es ist so wie ein Fremder, der einfach deinen Namen trägt. Du hast halt zufällig denselben Kumpel wie ich, was natürlich schon mal eine gewisse Gesinnungsallianz darstellt. Aber mit dem waren wir im Theater und der saß im Theater und hat ab der zweiten Minute konstant gehustet. Durchgehend. Es war kein Malhusten. Man kennt es ja, man kennt es nur meistens von weiter weg. Genau. Also jeder von uns war ja schon mal im Theater, im Kino oder in der Oper oder wherever und es ist ja dann doch so, dass immer irgendwo jemand niest. Selten neben einem direkt. Das stimmt. Ja, es ist immer so. Aber es istgelehrend. Das ist so, wie wenn man so ein Kikeriki hört von so einem Hahn. Das ist immer so aus einer gewissen Entfernung. Es ist nie der Hahn, der direkt neben dir steht. Das ist immer so in der Ah, okay, alles klar. Es ist immer entfernt. Und so stimmt ist das auch. Aber der muss halt einfach durchgehend gehuset. ich will ich aus dem Stück raus, keine Ahnung, wer dieser Hamlot-Typ ist, sondern war nur noch gedanklich bei ihm. Dieser Hä, nee, Hamlot. War nur noch bei ihm und dachte mir, wie kommt er da jetzt wieder raus? Und er hat wirklich einfach gerustet, locker vier, fünf Minuten und ist aufgestimmt und gegangen. Vor allem würde man ja gerne dem, okay, spannend, müssen wir vielleicht nochmal darauf zugrücken, dass er einfach gegangen ist. Er ist einfach gegangen.
Hätte ich nicht erwartet. Aber auch hier die Frage. vier, fünf Minuten und ist aufgestimmt und gegangen. Vor allem würde man ja gerne dem, okay, spannend, müssen wir vielleicht noch mal drauf zugrücken,
dass er einfach gegangen ist, hätte ich nicht
erwartet. Aber auch hier die Frage,
er ist ein Kumpel vom Kumpel. Man will ja dem
Theaterpublikum eigentlich mitteilen,
er ist eigentlich ein Fremder für mich.
Er sitzt zwar zwei Plätze neben mir,
aber gedanklich könnte er genauso ganz hinten sitzen.
Problem ist halt, dass das ganze Theater
euch zusammen hat kommen sehen
und natürlich ihr wahrscheinlich auch im gleichen Alter wart, weshalb ihr so ein bisschen in die gleiche Peergroup gesteckt wurdet. Heißt, die haben euch irgendwie zusammengesehen als Einheit. Ja. Ich möchte aber einen Schild hochhalten und sagen, dass der Zufall wollte, dass wir jetzt hier nebeneinander sitzen, ich habe eigentlich nichts mit ihm zu tun, weil wenn jetzt eine ältere Frau neben dir plötzlich einen Hustenanfall bekommen hätte, würdest du ja keine bösen Blicke ernten. Überhaupt nicht. Das Theater hat aber auch gesehen, wie wir diese zwei Minuten, in der der gemeinsame Freund kurz auf der Toilette war, unerträglich awkward nebeneinander standen, wo plötzlich dann so das Mittelstück weg ist und dann so wie so Dominosteine, die man so aneinander legt, so fünf auf der einen, zwei auf der einen, und das mittlere Stück verbindet. Und sod es weg ist, hast du fünf und drei, es passt nicht mehr zusammen und dann so, ähm, kennst du Sherlock diese Serie mit, Moment kurz, aber ihr musstet ja nicht, ach so, der Kumpel ist weggegangen, diese klassische Terrorsituation, ja, kannst du Sherlock die Serie, nee, kein Fan. Ich habe irgendwie die erste vorgeguckt. Ich habe auch keinen Fernseher bei mir zu Hause. Ich habe auch keinen Laptop. Ich trage auch keine Schuhe, wie du siehst. Ich bin so einer. Okay. Es ist halt so ein bisschen in der aktuellen Zeit Sherlock Holmes. Ich mag es gerne, vom Theater noch mal so still zu haben, dass man sich schon ein bisschen auf das Stück vorbereiten kann und so. Und ich lese ja auch gerade dieses Flyer hier, wo man sich auf das Stück vorbereiten kann. Gesundheit. Nee, wie, also ich habe einfach gerne ein bisschen die Stimme.
Aber ich meine,
der Intro-Song ist cool.
Das ist eine gute Musik.
Wobei nicht so singen war, ne?
Nee.
Das ist irgendwie...
Stefan spielt uns heute seine Lieblings-Intro-Form. Ja gut, aber du hast noch... Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, daGitarre am Musikabend. Auch vorbei jetzt einfach, Sherlock. Wurde sehr schlecht, dann ist es vorbei. Dann haben die Darkwiller gemacht, auch nicht so geil, jetzt ist einfach weg, okay. Privatiers sind das jetzt. Ja, aber ist doch in Ordnung. Das machen die jetzt, finde ich auch in Ordnung. Ist doch in Ordnung. Finde ich auch in Ordnung. Aber er ist einfach gegangen, er ist letzten Endes einfach gegangen und hat dann einfach die restlichen acht Stunden, von denen ich nichts mehr verstanden habe, weil ich den Anfang nicht mitbekommen habe, und am Anfang ist ja oft so eine Prophezeiung, taucht dann Geist auf und sagt, hier, pass auf, und Geist natürlich, ich sofort, musste natürlich einmal rauslassen, wusste aber, der tritt in der zweiten Szene wieder ab, und dann verstehst du natürlich gar nichts mehr. Okay, ich finde es spannend, wenn zwei Leute aufeinandertreffen, von denen du weißt, die würden sich mögen. Wir waren auch mal im Kino gemeinsam mit einem anderen Kumpel und da wusste ich, dass ihr euch beiden verstehen würdet eigentlich, dachte ich. Aber es ist halt doch erstmals ein bisschen awkward, weil ihr kennt euch nicht, man weiß nicht genau. Also es ist nur, aber es steht nur, dass man kennt sich nicht zwischen euch. So man weiß genau, was der eine Interesse hat, was der eine liest, was der andere mag, man weiß, was der andere mag und man weiß, die würden sich gut verstehen. Man will eigentlich ganz gerne bei diesen, weil man steht ja auch daneben und verliert Lebenszeit, in dem Moment, wo man daneben steht und zwei Freunde, die man hat, tauschen erst mal so diese Oberflächlichkeiten aus. Und du studierst noch? Nee, aber nein. Du willst so direkt die Verpackung abziehen und so, das muss gar nicht sein. Ich weiss ja, ich kenne euch beide, keiner von euch hat Bock auf diesen Smalltalk. Ihr wollt direkt irgendwie Gags machen und dann direkt im Leben sein, im Jetzt, Eindrücke aufnehmen und darüber die reflektieren. Und dann will man eigentlich so sagen, so, bei dem ist das passiert, bei dem ist das passiert. Man will so, wie man das manchmal kennt von Serien, vorneweg, man will so einen Schnelldurchlauf. Ja genau, so einen Steckbrief. So, das ist dein Leben gewesen, das ist dein Leben gewesen, so, und jetzt seid beste Freunde. Aber die Hierarchie war recht klar zwischen uns. Du warst der gemeinsame Freund natürlich, aber ich habe dann auch gesagt so, ich gehe jetzt noch mal kurz aufs Klo. Und dann meinte er so, ja, kannst du vielleicht kurz meine Weintrauben mitnehmen und die waschen? Ja. Und das war so eine Ansage einfach, wo ich dachte, okay, wir kennen uns seit drei Minuten und ich soll deine Weintrauben waschen.
Ich natürlich liebend gerne gemacht, weil ich mir dachte, okay, das ist, wir sind direkt weit über den Smalltalk hinaus mittlerweile, wenn ich seine Weintrauben wasche. Und dann war ich der einzige Trottel, der in der, in dem Kino-Toilette am Waschbecken eine Plastikpackung Weintrauben gewaschen hat. Also ich finde, was für diesen Vorschlag spricht, so unangenehm es jetzt auch klingt, ist ja, dass die Andersartigkeit, Weintrauben im Kino mitzunehmen und zu waschen, ja so lustig ist, dass es irgendwie ein lustiger Spruch ist. Absolut, es ist so verrückt, vor allem es macht direkt ein paar Türen auf. Erstens, okay, du bist kriminell, du schmuggelst Lebensmittel ins Kino, Punkt eins. Mit dir kann man Pferde stehlen. Genau, du akzeptierst mich als Komplizen in deiner Kriminalität, was schon mal eine Ehrung ist. Irgendwann können wir darüber reden, dass mit dem kann man Pferde stehlen, so gebraucht wird für viel geringere Sachen als eigentlich Pferde stehlen. Ja, stimmt. In was für einer Zeit war das so ein Satz, mit dem kann man Pferde stehlen, indem man es so locker flockig gesagt hat, als wäre das ein total Kavaliersdelikt, Pferde zu stehlen. Ja, aber mit mir kann man Weintrauben waschen. Ja, mit dir. Kann man mitnehmen. Und ich meine, er war ein bisschen gekränkt, dass er mir dann den gesamten Film keine Weintraube angeboten hat, obwohl ich sie gewaschen habe, aber auch gut. Also ich finde das auf mehreren Ebenen einfach interessant. Der nimmt Weintrauben mit, in dem Wissen, ich muss die noch waschen vorm Kino. Ich hätte die dann zu Hause gewaschen oder hat er die, also es ist verrückt, aber waren auf jeden Fall bestimmt sehr lecker. Er hat sehr glücklich geschaut, als er sie gegessen hat und ich hatte nichts. Aber auch direkt eine Hierarchie-Ansage, ne? Also wirklich ein bisschen zu sagen, ich bin hier der Boss, ihr wascht meine Weintrauben.
Vor allem, also ich bin auch der Typ, ich bin ja was so was Essen und so angeht, eh so sensibel irgendwie, aber ich könnte dann nicht mir nochmals einen Rieseneimer Popcorn kaufen.
Wenn eher so dieses, oh, ich habe meine Weintrauben dabei, ich bin ausserhalb der normalen Popcorn-Fastfood-Junkfood-Ebene, ich habe Weintrauben mitgebracht. Erstens, ich glaube eh nicht daran, Snacks zu kaufen. Zweitens, ich habe gesunde Snacks. Ich hätte mich nicht getraut, da jetzt nochmal den riesen Jumbo-Eimer Popcorn zu nehmen. Oder Ben & Jerry's Eis. Nee, du willst nicht der Typ sein dann. Sind Mais-Flocken die einzigen Dinge, die man poppen kann? Nee. Das ist die Frage. Es gibt ja bei den Cornflakes auch noch die Rice Krispies. Also anscheinend kann man auch Reis poppen. Die Frage ist, wie und was ist das eigentlich? Kann man Erbsen poppen? So, ich weiß, jetzt ist für dich, jetzt geht's kurz, okay, dein Blick geht in den Himmel. Und jetzt wird weit in die Luft, weit in der Nacht. Das Gesicht wurde eingefroren, kurz bei Florentin war eingefroren, Blick in den Himmel. Ich glaube, du kannst mit genug Willen alles puffen, das ist kein Problem. Puffen? Ich glaube, es ist ja auch so, Cornflakes sind ja auch einfach eine andere Art von Maispuffung. Die sind erst so plattgedrückt und dann gepufft, Popcorn ist erst klein. Gepufft und dann gedrückt? Okay, ja, wir wissen es nicht. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber... Sorry, das war jetzt die Stelle im Podcast, wo wir dann mal was nicht wussten. Wo wir uns kurz... Die ist jetzt aber auch vorbei. Schneiden wir auch vielleicht raus. Die ist auch vorbei. Ich war letztens auch im Kino bei einer Premiere und da gab es dann Popcorn. Warum sagen Leute, die immer bei den Premieren sind, immer das dabei? Naja, weil es eine andere Situation ist, weil es nicht diese, ich kaufe mir normales Popcorn-Situation ist, sondern da gibt es dann so große Bereiche mit so Popcorn-Tüten und da gab es Kokosnuss oder Lavendel. Was, was? Das war dann auch so, wo ich erstmal der Abend ist für mich ab dem Punkt gelaufen. Weil ich bin ab jetzt nur noch in der Welt, habe ich mich richtig entschieden, hätte ich mich anders entscheiden müssen, gehe ich für die vergleichsweise sichere Entscheidung Kokosnusspopcorn, weil da weißt du ungefähr, wie es schmeckt, oder gehe ich die exotische Variante Lavendelpopcorn, was ich eher als Geruch kenne, denn als Geschmack. Und die Frage ist, kriegt mein Gehirn die Transferleistung hin von, das kennst du eigentlich als Geruch und jetzt als Geschmack. Machen wir mal einen Geruch nach für alle Zuschauer. Weil ich habe das beste Gericht, was ich fast jemals gegessen habe, waren Lavendel-Ravioli. Und es war einfach nur, es war unfassbar toll. Es war so lecker, gut war auch in Italien, die Sonne scheint einem auf den Kopf, man lebt die Dolce Vita. Und dann kriegt man halt Lavendel-Ravioli, sagt man nicht nein, ist es dann. Aber Ravioli sind diese Kissen, wo was drin ist. Kissen, ja. Und da waren Lavendel drin? Die sogenannten Kissen-Nudeln. Und da waren drin? Ja, da war dieses weisse Zeug, Ricotta drin und Lavendel. War auch drin. Geschmack, auch drin, aber auch, das stimmt schon, diese penetranten Nachfragen sind legitimiert, auch obendrauf noch drüber gestreut. Es war fantastisch lecker, es war unglaublich lecker. Und jetzt lustigerweise am Wochenende war ich auch essen und da gab es auch Lavendel-Eis, tatsächlich, Lavendel-Eis. Und das war auch lecker, also Lavendel, unterschätzt man das nicht, tut mir das nicht ab als irgendwie ein angenehmer Geruch oder etwas, was gegen Motten hilft.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, auch, das kannst du auch.
Ja, ja, ja, ist auch gutes Essen.
Ich glaube, ich habe in meinem Leben einfach zu viel Lavendel gerochen, dass ich jetzt noch den Transfer hinkriege.
Es gibt manche Sachen, die riechst du eher und es gibt manche Sachen, die schmeckst du eher.
Und ich habe auch früh gelernt, weil ich war ein sehr hungriges Kind, ich habe früh gelernt, nicht alles, was gut riecht, schmeckt gut.
Ich habe reihenweise Seifen gegessen, weil ich mir dachte, das riecht so gut. Das muss, wenn das ein Reib so gut schmeckt, dann ist es immer noch gut. Stellt sich raus, nein, Krankenhaus. Krankenhaus? Naja, das schäumt dann auf und so. Naja, also was mich stört ist, bei sowas wie, das schmeckt nach Seife, Lavendel schmeckt nach Seife, das ist mir zu fies. Da hat sich die Seifenlobby jetzt einfach Lavendel einverleibt als guten Geruch. Ja, vor allem es gibt Seife, die nach allem riecht. Also du kannst, wenn du sagst, nämlich nach Seife, das ergibt ja gar keinen Sinn. Ich meine, das Problem ist halt, wie ich bei guter Arbeit häufiger mal Himbeer mir gekauft habe und schön Himbeer gegessen habe und so aufs Klo gegangen bin, um mir dann mit der Himbeerseife, die es da gab, auf dem Klo die Hände zu waschenchen. Es war so unbefriedigend. Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, es ist nur geil, Himbeerseife, wenn man literally alles davor geht, ausser Himbeeren. Weil dann hast du das Gefühl, du hast die Finger nicht richtig gewaschen. Du musst eigentlich immer dir Seife-Geschmacksrichtung kaufen, wo du weisst, das werde ich selber nie verzehren. Wenn du Melone hast, dann kauf dir Melonenseife, weil du weisst, du kriegst jeden Geruch von deinen Händen weg. Und da war Lavendel natürlich eine sichere Wette, jahrelang. Jetzt fängt man hingegen an, sich Lavendel in den Mund zu stopfen die ganze Zeit, da hilft das natürlich nicht mehr. Ja, es funktioniert nicht. Es ist das gleiche Problem wie Fisherman's Friend, die es jetzt mittlerweile auch in verschiedenen Geschmacksrichtungen gibt. Zum Beispiel habe ich gesehen, Fisherman's Friend Lakritze, und man sich auch fragt, was passiert, wenn ich Lakritze gegessen habe und dann meinen Atem auffrischen will. Mit Fisherman's Friends Lakritzes funktioniert das einfach nicht. Genau, funktioniert nicht. Und jetzt gibt es noch das Problem, weil in Köln gibt es jetzt Kettenfett. Wirklich. Das ist Lakritz-Likör, sowas wie Jägermeister. Stell dir mal an sich vor, man isst den ganzen Tag Lakritz, will dann mit dem Fisherman's Friends Lakritz-Geschmack den Lakritz-Geschmack aus dem Mund bekommen, um dann feiern gehen zu können, endlich, wo man dann Lakritz-Likör trinkt. Ja, und dann nach dem Feiern kommst du nach Hause, willst verbergen, dass du Lakritz-Schnaps getrunken hast, haust dir nochmal einen Lakritz-Wüttel. Und die Mutter sagt, hauch mich mal an. Ja, schon verrückt. So, muss man sagen, okay, haben wir das Lakritz-Thema jetzt abgeschlossen. Ja. Können wir jetzt weitermachen. Ja, ich bin immer noch ein bisschen näserig, glaube ich. Weil wir hier eine Präsenz im Raum haben. Sollen wir den Raum ... Das hat mal eine Co-Autorin gemacht, kann man jetzt ja mal sagen. Bei der ersten Staffel von How to Sell Drugs wurde der Raum gesaged. Was? Ja, und ich schwank dann zwischen ... Moment, erst mal gesaged, also exorziert? Ja, es wurde ein Exorzismus. Der Raum wurde von Bad Vibes. Okay, ich zitiere, sie war Amerikanerin. Aber Bad Vibes wirklich im Sinne von Vibes oder wirklich spektrale Wesen? Also ich glaube, wenn du in den Raum gekommen wärst, dann hättest du erst mal einen Niesanfall gehabt. So spektral war es dann, glaube ich, schon. Also sie kam herein, das EMF spielt verrückt, und dann hat sie so Pinne genommen, angezündet. Was, Pinne? So Pinne, so grosse Pinne, also so Stöcke. Sagt man das nicht in Süddeutschland? Nee. So grosse Stöcke, die man anzünden kann, wie so Riesenräucherstäbchen, angezündet vorne und dann durch die Ecken des Raumes. Die Ecken sind dann immer das Problem. Die Geister verstecken sich in den Ecken, oder? In den letzten Ecken. Und dann wurde sie zu den Ecken gegangen und hat dann da was vor sich gefaselt und dann den Rauch in diese Ecken gesprüht und so. Und ja, roch danach besser, muss man schon sagen. Will man denn nicht Geister haben? Also in einem Raum, in dem geschrieben wird, eine kreative Sache macht, warum will man denn da keine Geister haben?
Ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was die genau machen.
Ich behaupte es mal, die helfen einem nicht dabei,
irgendwie Plotholes zu füllen,
sondern ich glaube, die
sorgen eher dafür, dass man sich anschreit und so.
Also wenn, sagt man ja, ein Dämon hat
von dir Besitz ergriffen,
pipapo, ich glaube, das ist nicht so tolles.
Man sagt aber auch bei manchen genialen Künstlern, die waren vom Teufel besessen. Paganini oder so. Also wenn du vom Teufel besessen wärst, kann ja auch sein, dass du dann ganz schnell wie mit einem Rausch tippst und ganz tolle Geschichten erzählst. Ja, oder hasserfüllten Scheiss. Aber was mit den Ghostbustern? Also wenn es reicht, jetzt irgendwie eine Kerze anzuzünden, um Geister zu vertreiben. Ja, das war ja irgendwann ein 80er, 90er Phänomen. Ja, du meinst, die Technologie ist so weit fortgeschritten, dass man heute einen Traumfänger und ein Räucherstäbchen braucht und nicht mehr diese Science-Sci-Fi-Kanonen. Genau, man muss sich einfach hinten diese von diesen Räucherstäbchen, dann die Verpackung durchlesen. Und wenn das eine Ghostbusters-approved Variante ist, dann kann man, ja, wirst du einfach die Geister schön los. Aber guck mal, das ist auch ein Sketch, oder? Ja. Das ist auch ein Sketch, die modernen Ghostbusters, who you're gonna call, ne, ne, ne, auch so mit so einem Auto und dann geht man raus und dann, okay, das ist ein harter Geist und dann so ein Traumfänger und ein Räucherstäbchen. Ja, keine Ahnung, so eineinhalb Minuten oder so. Wollen wir diesen Sketch verkaufen? Studio Schmidt oder irgendwas? Ja.
Wenn ihr ihn wollt, zehn Euro.
Das Problem ist ja, dass niemand mehr solche Sketche macht, die wirklich gar keine Relevanz haben, die komplett aus dem Nichts kommen. Ja, das stimmt, das ist dieser Late-Night-Fluch, du musst immer eine Relevanz haben, ja.
Das war ja immer unser großes Problem, warum wir im Late-Night-Kosmos ja auch nie funktioniert haben, wir beiden, so richtig, als Autoren, weil wir ja nie auf relevante Ideen gestoßen sind, sondern meistens Nonsens ausgedacht haben, der hat schon irgendwie seine Daseinsberechtigung, aber halt oft nicht in einer wöchentlichen Sende. Der nächste kreative Schritt, das halt irgendwie zu biegen. Das kann ja Zuschauer bei sich zu Hause im Köpfchen machen. Das kriegt man schon hin. Man kann dann so irgendwie von wegen ja, Veganer-Hype und Öko-Hype oder so, was ist jetzt alles auch noch Öko, ja, jetzt sind die Ghostbusters auch noch Öko. Das kriegst du schon irgendwie so lame hingedrückt. Das ist schon kein Problem. Aber dann hatten wir, glaube ich, keine Geister mehr. Erstmal. Und die sind dann für immer weg oder die kommen nach einer Zeit wieder zurück? Ich denke, man muss es regelmäßig machen. Die kommen dann zurück. Es ist wie Schädlingsbekämpfung im Prinzip. Und also, allein die Tatsache, dass sie Geister in dem Raum vermutet hat, heißt, da sind auch Leute in dem Raum gestorben. Wie kommen die denn sonst? Die bleiben ja immer da, wo sie gestorben sind. Also, ich habe immer Witze darüber gemacht, weil früher in den gleichen Gebäuden war so eine Dokusoap-Produktionsfirma. Okay. Die haben so Frauentauschartig. Und ich habe immer die Witze gemacht, dass die sehr schlechte Ideen gestorben sind. Und irgendwie, hier ist der Geist des deutschen Fernsehens gestorben und solche Witze. Oder der Grund, warum die nur Trash gemacht haben, war, dass halt die Geister, die die ganze Zeit genervt haben. Das alles, diese ich auch alle schon gemacht, ohne dass ich anwesend war. Okay, alles klar. Dann darf ich jetzt keinen Spaß damit haben. Nee, wir haben damit jetzt keinen Spaß. Aber ich finde das toll. Genau so habe ich nämlich auch reagiert. Und ja, nee, sie fand das, glaube ich, nicht so lustig. Das waren nicht die Geister, die sie meinte damit. Es gibt natürlich verschiedene, das ist ja klar.
Ja, also fantastisch. Ich fand es spannend und so. Und ja, ich glaube, es war eher so darum, dass man eine schlechte Stimmung da rausbekommen wollte. Falls ihr überlegt, warum ist hier immer so schlechte Stimmung, ich komme gerne vorbei, ich habe die Nase, ich habe den Riecher für Geister. mein Auto ist auch so eine grosse Nase,
einfach so eine grosse Nase mit so einem
Geist durchgestrichen, dann komme ich bei euch
vorbei, habe auch so ein Mobil und dann kann ich mal bei euch ein bisschen schnüffeln und dann schaue ich mal, ob ich eine allergische Reaktion auf ein spektrales Wesen habe oder nicht. Und wenn ja, dann wird deine Kollegin noch mal gerufen und dann kommen die richtig schweren Geschwitze. Wie damals diese Pillenautos, kennst du die? Diese großen, diese kleinen, was waren das so Fiat 500s, die anstatt dieser, es gab ja auch diese Red Bull-Autos mit der großen Red Bull-Flasche hinten drauf, große Pillen drauf. Einfach nur so ein riesiges Pillenfahrzeug. Und viele meiner Freunde damals, Schulfreunde sind das gefahren. Und dann bringst du einfach von Apotheken dann Pillen oft zu älteren Menschen. Menschen. Ah. Und so stelle ich mir deinen Nasen-Past-Videos vor. Ja. Aber es ist schon interessant, also ich habe letztens nachgedacht, weil es ist unfassbar, wie effizient Körperöffnungen sind. Also es gibt keine Körperöffnung, die nur eine Funktion hat. Es ist immer Doppelbelegung. Du hast immer mehrere
Körperöffnungen, die machen einen Job, was ja nicht
selbstverständlich ist. Nee, was machen den Ohren noch mehr
als Hörer? Ohren sind keine
Körperöffnung. Das nehmen wir jetzt mal
das nehmen wir jetzt mal, das ist eine starke These,
Stefan, jetzt nehmen wir das mal raus,
aber jetzt nehmen wir zum Beispiel den Mund.
Super Körperöffnung. Top drei
der Körperöffnungen, bei mir
ganz klarer eins der Mund, atmen, essen, reden, perfekt. Kauen kann er auch, ne? Schmecken. Schmecken hast du wahrscheinlich schon gesagt. Aber auch ansonsten, jede Körperöffnung hat mehr als eine Funktion. Was macht denn das Arschloch noch mehr? Ja, Entsorgung von Feststoffen und Gasen. Ist nämlich. Ist nämlich auch nicht selbstverständlich. Es wäre ja möglich, dass ein separates Loch für die Gase zuständig ist. Halt irgendwie so in der Schulter oder sowas in der Richtung. Weil du kannst es ja auch überall hinlegen. Es kann ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten sein. Oder dass du nochmal ein extra Loch hast zum Urinieren und ein anderes Körperteil zur Fortpflanzung. Aber dass das einfach alles zusammengelegt wird, ist doch genial. Ja, das finde ich auch genial. Der Körper ist unglaublich effizient. Es ist unfassbar effizient. Vor allem Körperöffnung ist ja ein Problem, weil da kommt Sand rein und irgendwie Dünen. Sand, es ist eigentlich nur Sand. Es ist das größte Feind von Körperöffnung. Wenn du in einem Sandsturm bist oder so oder am Strand, da kann unendlich viel auch, was mich an Dune immer so abgeturnt
hat, war immer,
weil es ist ja immer,
bei so Sci-Fi-Filmen will man ja immer
dann in die Welt und so, aber
Dune klingt immer schon so nach,
zu viel Sand.
So die Wolkenstadt von
Star Wars oder so. Ja, geil.
Aber Dune klingt nach, okay, viel
zu viel Sand, kommt mal nach Hause, aus dem Kino und muss erst mal die Schuhe ausschütteln.
Aber Sand ist schon faszinierend. Also habe ich, ich habe letztens eine Sanduhr gesehen und dann dachte ich, warum rieselt der Sand immer gleich schnell?
So, wenn da Wasser drin wäre, würde ja der Wasserdruck dafür sorgen, dass mehr Wasser unten rausgeht.
Weil bei einer Sanduhr ist ja egal, wie groß die ist, die rieselt immer in der gleichen Geschwindigkeit. Ich habe die in so einem Laden gesehen, da habe ich echt überlegt, ob ich den Verkäufer das fragen soll. Ich weiß nicht, ob der mir das hätte beantwortet. Naja, wenn das ein Sanduhrladen war, hätte das ja wahrscheinlich beantworten können. Ich nehme an, das war eher so Karstadt. Bitte halten Sie fest, in zwei Minuten wird der Laden umgedreht. Achtung, halten Sie sich fest. Wie lange haben Sie heute noch geöffnet? Und dann so. Sekunde, Sekunde, wo war sie? Ein Moment, wo war sie? Da war sie. Die Blaue, Rita, die Blaue. Und dann so, ja, noch so, ja, so vier Zentimeter so. Ja, sag mal, acht Zentimeter, ich habe es schon. Oder sowas. Moment mal kurz. Aber auch ein guter Laden. Ich glaube, weil es gibt verschiedene Sandarten. Ich war jetzt auch über Ostern mal wieder in meiner Heimat, habe alte Fotoalben durchgeschaut und so und habe auch gesehen, ich war ein Sandburg-Afficionado. Oh, wirklich? Ich habe die Sandburg gebaut. Ich hatte aber auch so ganz cooles Werkzeug dafür, weil in der Nähe, in Trabemünde an der Ostsee, da gab es immer Sandworld. Sandworld war eine große Ausstellung, wo Künstler, es klingt schrecklich wegen des Sandes, es klingt wie Dune, aber es war fantastisch, weil du hast riesige Kunstwerke gehabt, teilweise drei Meter hoch und genauso breit und hast da irgendwie, haben die Michael Jackson und Louis C.K. in dem Stand. Kevin Spacey. Kevin Spacey, ne, es war, ach gut, again, es war alles so 2003 oder so, aber, und es ist nicht gut gealtert, diese ganze Ego. Aber die haben fantastische Sachen in den Sand geschnitzt, Burgen und so weiter, oder gut, Pyramiden, ein bisschen boring jetzt, aber auch tollere Sachen, wie zum Beispiel den Taj Mahal, so was, den Kölner Dom, sah alles unglaublich toll aus und wahnsinnig detailgetreu. Und teilweise auch Brücken und so, wo man sagt, wie geht das denn? Als Kind ist man ja fasziniert, weil man denkt, Sandburgen sind die Sandburgen, die man immer am Strand sieht. Dann bin ich in den Laden gegangen und hat mir so eine Maurerkelle und so Sachen besorgt, um dann besser Sandburgen machen zu können und vor allem richtig glatt arbeiten zu können. Also noch so Pinsel und so Sachen zum Verziehen gemacht. Und dann hatte ich da auch einen Kumpel am Strand, wir haben ganz viele Burgen gebaut, die natürlich viel besser waren als andere. Das Leute vorbeikommen, Ziel war, Leute kommen vorbei, bleiben stehen, gucken sich das an. Das ist der Erfolg des Stehenbleibens. So, das war unser Erfolg. Langsames Gehen ist okay, aber Stehenbleiben ist der eigentliche Erfolg. Das ist das Ziel gewesen. Und deswegen war ich da Sandburg-Affizionado. Und was war deine größte Kreation? Also wo schaust du am stolzesten darauf zurück? Ich glaube, es war
eine Brücke.
Eine bestimmte Brücke oder einfach
eine Brücke? Oder schön die Golden Gate? Es war, wir haben die
Rialto-Brücke nachempfunden
und
nein, ich weiß es nicht mehr, ehrlich gesagt.
Was ich aber sagen wollte und was ich dadurch
erfahren habe, es gibt verschiedene Sandarten.
Nämlich bei Sandworld
haben die nämlich ein bisschen gecheatet. Die hatten nämlich nicht unseren Ostseesandstrand. Ja gut. Sondern den sogenannten Beton. Sondern die hatten, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie aus Tunesien oder Marokko oder so sich Sand geholt. Und der ist halt ein bisschen, wenn man dann mikroskopisch reingeht, viel dicker und eckiger. Und dadurch, und der Ausdruckstrand ist halt runder und diesen eckigen, damit kannst du halt viel besser bauen und kannst auch Dinge bauen, die dann nicht so schnell einstürzen und du kannst viel besser, ja, detailgetreuer arbeiten und es ist viel stabiler. Und deswegen glaube ich nicht daran, dass Sanduhren alle gleichzeitig gleich schnell sind, weil Sand ist unterschiedlich beschaffen.
Aber wir können uns einigen, innerhalb einer Sanduhr, die läuft nicht am Anfang schneller, wenn noch mehr Gewicht drauf geht, als am Ende.
Ich glaube nicht. Wie gesagt, ich wurde relativ schnell aus dem Sanduhrladen rausgeschmissen, weil mir niemand die Uhrzeit sagen konnte.
Die sagt, ja, ihr mit eurer tollen Uhr. Aber so ein Sanduhrladen, das gab es bei uns früher, ich habe ja meinen Zivildienst mit Kindern gemacht, und da gab es dann immer, wenn die richtig frech waren, haben die eine Sanduhr bekommen. Und dann wurden belohnt dafür. Ne, die haben Sanduhr gehasst. Die haben wirklich gehasst. Haben die das Konzept Zeit gehasst oder was haben sie gehasst? Allein die Vorstellung, dass ihre Kindheit verstreicht, das war für die die schlimmste Strafe. Wie poetisch. Was eine tolle Gruppe Kinder, wenn sie als Bestrafung die Fruchtet eine Sanduhr bekommen. Eine Sanduhr und ein Buch. Die Visualisierung ihrer zerrinnenden Kindheit war das Schlimmste, was du diesen Kindern antun kannst. Es gab verschiedene Sanduhren, die hatten verschiedene Zeiten, also eine Minute, fünf Minuten, zehn Minuten und dann, wenn das Kind richtig frech war, hat es die zehn Minuten Sanduhr bekommen und musste damit raus vor die Tür und dann durfte es erst wieder rein, wenn die Zeit abgelaufen ist. Und das erste, was ich mir natürlich als jugendlicher Zivil gedacht habe, ist die Cheaten. Ich würde immer cheaten. Ich würde die Zeit drei Minuten laufen lassen, dann wieder umdrehen und dann zurückkommen. Und deswegen habe ich mir extra mal die Mühe gemacht, die Zeit selber zu stoppen. Dass wenn die rausgeschickt wurden, habe ich selber auf meinem Handy die Zeit gestoppt und kein einziges Kind hat gecheatet. Keines. Wo ich mir dachte, Leute, das ist doch das, was euch eigentlich das Schulsystem lehrt, ist Betrügen. Das ist doch die wichtigste Lektion, wie man spickt, wie man abschreibt, wie man irgendwie gerade noch so mit einer vier Minus durch das Schuljahr kommt, das sind doch die Skills, die man hat. Aber was bist du, können wir darüber reden, was du für ein riesengroßes Arschloch bist, dass du da anfängst zu überprüfen, ob die Sanduhren funktionieren. Aber, nee, ich bin die überhaupt markiert, ich bin die markiert. Ich bin eigentlich das Gegenteil von einem Arschloch. Ich bin ein Saubermann. Und zwar bin ich, weil ich hätte mich nämlich nur dann beschwert, wenn die nicht gecheatet haben. Wenn die gecheatet hätten, hätte ich gesagt, ja klar, würde ich auch machen. Aber irgendwann dachte ich mir dann, also war ich dann so das Teufelchen auf der Schulter von einem Kind, wo ich mir dachte so, soll ich denen mal sagen, dass sie relativ einfach betrügen können und schneller ihre Strafe absetzen können und mehr von ihrer süssen, süssen Kindheit genießen können? Von der sie solche Angst haben, dass sie ihnen durch die Finger rennt. Indem sie Hase und Salat-Kohl spielen oder was auch immer. Ja, aber niemand hat Betrugung. Ich hätte die markiert, die Sanduhr, Auf den oberen Teil des Glases O geschrieben, auf den unteren Teil U zum Beispiel. Stark. Und dann? Oder Pfeile drauf gemalt oder in Bewegungsrichtung gemalt. So, und wenn die dann hätten, die den Cheat nicht anwenden können. Da hätten sie nur versuchen können, irgendwie doll rumzuwackeln oder so. Okay, aber glaube ich auch nicht. Nee, ich glaube auch nicht. Sand ist einfach unkorrumpierbar. Verläierbar. Verlässlich. Da kannst du nicht schieten. Sand ist einfach die Konstante. Gibt es denn genormte ... Konstante. Konstante. Konstanza. Die Konstante meine ich. Gibt es denn genormte Sandarten für Sand? Also gibt es staatlich abgenommenen Sanduhr-Sand? Ist der besonders fein, hat der eine bestimmte Dicke. Da müssen wir jetzt irgendwie so bei Hasbro oder so Brettspielherstellern anrufen. Die kennen sich ja am besten mit Sanduhren eigentlich aus, immer diese eine Minute oder so, die dann immer umdrehst. Aber wenn du die jetzt nur 45 Grad neigst, riesen die dann schneller oder langsamer? Langsamer, ne?
Ich glaube, man kann gar nicht betrügen mit Sanduhr.
Vielleicht gibt es einen Sanduhr-Experten da draußen,
der uns mal so ein Diagramm
zeichnen kann
oder ein Bild und malt oder so.
Oder wählt mal
für eure Antwort auf die Frage,
das Medium, das euch am wenigsten
liegt. Also angenommen,
ihr seid jetzt Physiker oder Geologe oder so und kennt euch damit aus und seid PowerPoint-Präsentation und so gewohnt, dann malt mal ein abstraktes Bild oder schreibt ein Gedicht. Also wählt das Medium, das erwarte ich jetzt, wählt das Medium, das ihr am wenigsten normalerweise benutzt. Wenn ihr Musiker seid, dann versucht eine Formel zu schreiben oder so. Also versucht mal, nicht den Inhalt. Mit dem Inhalt kennt ihr euch aus, und das möchte ich euch nicht nehmen. Versucht, vom Medium her mal aus eurer Kampferzone rauszukommen. Das fände ich toll. Ich habe mir gerade bei der Schwerkraft, wo ich mir gedacht habe, ja, wahrscheinlich rieselt es nicht unterschiedlich schnell durch, je nachdem, wie viel Sand sich oben noch angehäuft hat und so. Und dann kurz, musste ich an meinen lieben Freund Newton denken. Und dass ich neulich zum ersten Mal mich informiert habe über den grossen Prioritätsstreit, den grossen, grossen Streit zwischen Leibniz und Newton, wo ich gar nicht wusste, dass es so einen Riesenstreit gab. Ich bin Fan von solchem Streit. Das war ja damals schon ein grosser, der Stromstreit, die Stromkriege zwischen Tesla und Edison, auch schon spannend, Gleichstrom versus Gleichwechselstrom. Da gibt es die grosse Kriege in der Mathematik, Gödel gegen die anderen Typen da, auch irre. Was ist Unendlichkeit und so? Genau, und dann gab es, was ich nicht wusste, es gab einen riesengroßen Streit zwischen Newton, der natürlich für England und den Erfolg Englands stand, und Leibniz.. Beide waren eigentlich sehr, also zum einen hat Newton wenig Mathematik betrieben und sehr, sehr viel Physik und anderen Quatsch gemacht, hat auch in Himmel geguckt und so ein, die sind ganz Schwachsinn, hat viel über Optik geschrieben und so. Und Leibniz war sehr auf Mathematik fokussiert und hat dann ein paar Sachen gemacht, plötzlich haben wir angefangen mit Leibniz-Schar-Differenzialgleichen zu rechnen und sowas und haben, obwohl Newton das wohl eher mal erfunden hätte, es immer die Leibnizsche Variante genannt. Und es waren nie die beiden. Lustigerweise gilt es dann jetzt sozusagen, werden die beiden immer lustig gemalt, so als Comicfiguren, die sich so gegenseitig ins Gesicht boxen und man denkt so geil, so große intellektuelle Vordenker in der Geschichte haben sich dann so geprügelt.
Nein, oft waren es einfach nur, irgendwann haben die sich beide auch angebieft.
Am Anfang waren es aber wirklich nur einfach so Leute um die herum.
Und die beiden haben immer so cool reagiert, wo man sich wirklich mal eine Scheibe von abschneiden sollte.
Ja, die Leute wollten Drama.
Genau.
Aber die haben es ihnen nicht gegeben. Wo man auch sieht, es war zu wenig los damals, es war einfach zu wenig los. Da war wohl so eine Zeit, wo einfach lame war. Keine spannenden Sachen sind passiert, da wurden die auch so ein bisschen Drama anstacheln. Was war das so für ein Jahr ungefähr? Das, 1711. Und dann war es so, dass einer gesagt hat, ja hier, in diesem neuen Buch, da wird, lieber Newton, schauen Sie, da wird es Leibniz-Differentialgleichung genannt, aber das haben Sie doch schon eher gemacht und so und dann hat er sich so sehr nett geäußert, weil die beiden haben sich immer so wahnsinnig nette Briefe geschrieben und es war sehr, sehr süß mit anzuschauen und Leibniz hat dann auch mal einmal gesagt, wurde dann konfrontiert, irgendwie gibt es so einen Engländer, der dich irgendwie hier des Plagiats bezichtigt und so. Und er hat gesagt, ach, ich verstehe das doch auch. Der tritt halt für die Engländer ein. Und das wäre doch eher was, was man loben sollte, als den Schelten sollte, weil es ist doch was Tolles. Manchmal würde ich mir von meinen deutschen Kollegen auch wünschen, sich ein bisschen mehr blablabla, da wurde es ein bisschen zu lässisch, aber sehr nett, wo man auch sagt, so sollte man streiten, so sollte man streiten. Und es wurde dann hinten raus ein bisschen böser, bis dann Leibniz immer gestorben ist. Aber ich dachte, diese Streitkultur, die ist verloren gegangen. Das gibt es nicht mehr, dass man sich so sehr zurücknimmt und es ist ja auch dieses, man würde vielleicht sagen, so humble braggen. Weil es ist ja schon zwischen den Zeilen deutlich zu lesen, dass die sich gerade nicht so grün miteinander sind. Und es ist auch nicht sympathisch zu lesen. Ja, sich einfach weigern, den anderen als Feind anzuerkennen, weil man sich denkt, ach ja, das ist, also man steht drüber so. Es ist clever, es ist sehr clever. Es ist total clever, ja. Aber es liest sich auch ein bisschen passiv. Aber du kriegst halt wenig Likes für, ach ja, das ist okay, soll der machen, was er will. Das stimmt, ne? Da kriegst du halt keine Likes dafür. Aber das stimmt auch nicht ganz, weil damals ging es ja auch um Likes. Die Leute haben dann die Daumen hochgegoben oder also? Naja, in sehr langen lateinischen Schriftstücken, wo man erstmal sehr lange lesen muss und Latein lernen muss, um zu checken, ob es ein Daumen hoch oder Daumen runter ist. Aber ja, im Kern ging es ja auch darum, Anerkennung zu sammeln vom Volke oder nicht. Vielleicht sind das die Helden, die wir brauchen, Leibniz und Newton. Vielleicht kann man irgendwie so einen neuen Keks rausbringen, so einen Apfelkeks oder so. Dass man dann einfach so die als die Werbefiguren macht, irgendwie so Newton, der für den Apfel steht und Leibniz, der für den Keks steht. Und beide nehmen sich so in den Arm. Und beide nehmen sich in den Arm und dann hast du halt so einen leckeren Apfelkeks. Und beide hauen so einen Daumen hoch. Ja, so ein leckerer Butterkeks und dazwischen so eine saftige Apfelscheibe oder so. Toll. Das ist doch lecker, ist doch lecker und man lernt was über die Geschichte einfach. So, es gibt immer so dann so, auch so Chipsorten gibt es immer dann so Marokko und Afrika oder so. Ne, mal nach berühmten Leuten. Jetzt mal irgendwie so die Tesla-Chips oder so. Die sind dann halt so mit ... Mit was? Wechsel. Ja, halt mit Chili ein bisschen. Ein bisschen feurig. Das war die Werbung dieser Folge. Ja, das wird schon. Ich war neulich im Trainieren, im Fitnessstudio. Ich bin sehr stolz darauf, dass es gerade regelmäßig hinkriegt. Super. Ich freue mich darauf. Machst du immer noch dein Cyber-Strom-Schlag-Ding? Nee, das habe ich schon seit 100 Jahren nicht mehr gemacht. Gott sei Dank. Da Teslasche Schule. Wechselstrom wird durch den Körper gejagt. Nee, aber ich bin jetzt weg, bin ich jetzt von ab. Und dann gibt es da einen Raum, der so ein bisschen mein sozialer Horrorfilm ist. Weil der Raum ist eigentlich toll, der ist oft leer, ist einfach ein Raum, ist quasi im Keller des Fitnessstudios, da kann man alleine trainieren. Du hast überall quasi diese typischen Fitnessstudiospiegel angel an den Wänden, kannst aber, also kannst dich da, findest alles in den Regalen, kannst deine Übungen da machen, da ist oft niemand. Und man kann dann selber seine Musik anmachen, da läuft immer Musik, so, und man kann per Bluetooth, und ich finde diese Idee toll, und deswegen gehe ich auch gerne in den Raum, weil ich da meine eigene Musik anmachen könnte. Natürlich mache ich es nicht. Da läuft immer Hip-Hop und einmal habe ich Musik angemacht und zwar läuft immer so ein Hip-Hop-Radio. Einfach so coole Hip-Hop-Songs in einer Rotation von, sage ich mal, drei Stunden, weil ich habe noch nie gehört, dass es sich dann wiederholt hat. Und dann wollte ich auch mal selber Musik anmachen und habe dann eine Hip-Hop-Playlist bei Spotify genommen, was gut und gerne einfach die gleiche hätte sein können, um die dann laut anzumachen. Und dann habe ich mich gefreut, dass ich da Musik, weil ich bin so unsicher, ich würde niemals meine eigene Musik, die ich mögen würde, laut Dear Evan Hansen oder so, würde ich jetzt nicht anmachen da. Von daher habe ich dann das angemacht und einmal war vor mir dann jemand bereits in dem Raum, ist immer schon so ein bisschen so ein Downer, weil ich ja keine Lust drauf habe, dass ein anderer ist, der dann seine Übung gemacht und irgendwann schaut er mich an und fragt so, ist gut die Musik, die ich angemacht habe, ist gut für dich, passt alles und es lief Daft Punk. Oh ja, okay. Und ich dachte, hab natürlich sofort gesagt, ja cool, Daft Punk, mach doch jeder, ist doch geil, hab auch gesagt, ich war auch stolz, dass ich erkannt habe, was er da angemacht hat. Und sonst war Daft Punk, kann man ja auch gut so trainieren, geht nach vorne, energetisch, ist das irgendwie ein cooler Song. Konnte ich was mit anfangen und dann gesagt, ja cool, okay, mega, super. Und der nächste Song war Adele. Okay. Und dann ging der aus, Daft Punk, und es fing Adele an. Ja. So Somebody Like You oder sowas. Ja, es ist schwer eine Playlist zu judgen, während man drin ist in der Playlist, während man nur einen Song hat. Aber ich habe so euphorisch gesagt, dass mir Death Punk so gefiel. Verstehe. Ich habe so alles an mir und mein Körper gesagt, super, sehr gut, weil manche machen dann so Death Metal an und so und da habe ich dann meine Schwierigkeiten, sonst bin ich da sehr unempfindlich und man kann ja auch selber sich dann mal Musik in die Ohren machen oder sowas, aber also Death Punk gefiel mir und ich fand es gut mit ihm auf einer Wellenlänge zu sein, dann geht das Song aus und es lief Adele und was nicht mehr kam und da habe ich mich gefragt, wow, wie selbstbewusst muss man sein oder wie Musik unkritisch, weil es kam nicht mal dieser Blick zu mir, ob ich auch damit zufrieden wäre. Ah, okay, ja. Das heißt, er war sich bei Daft Punk unsicherer, ob mir das gefällt, als danach bei laut bei laut Adele, someone like you.
Das ist auch gut und vor allem du hast schon so euphorisch Daft Punk abgesegnet, dass du jetzt das aufrechterhalten musst und bei Adele einfach someone like you und du so Okay, one, two, okay, du bist richtig drin, einfach weil du es nicht diesen
Bruch darstellen willst.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe nicht mehr so euphorisch reagiert,
weil das war ja nicht so meine Musik
und fand ich dann eher blöd, aber da
wollte er nicht mehr meine
Zustimmung für Harbert. Ja, ist das schwer,
wahrscheinlich dachte er ja, okay, Playlist, abgesegnet
und er hat sich vielleicht bei der Playlist
was gedacht und dachte, die hat eine inhärente Struktur. Ja, aber die habe ich nicht gesehen. Die ist manchmal schwer zu sehen. Das ist vielleicht auch ein schönes Spiel, falls eins live oder so zuhört. Was ist die Playlist? Du spielst drei Songs vor, dem Promi-Gast, jetzt Bela B oder was auch immer, wer halt da ist, wer halt gerade im Haus, wer halt gerade Zeit hat.
Und dann muss der Promi sagen, was ist das für eine Playlist?
Also ist das die Ausgeblieb oder halt je spezieller, Songs, die in diesem Jahr veröffentlicht wurden oder gibt es hundertprozentig schon im Musikradio?
Ich glaube, es ist absolut unmöglich, sich neue Ideen für Musikradio auszudenken.
Aber falls ihr die noch nicht umgesetzt habt bei euch auf eurem Radiosender, dann bitteschön.
Hier ist Bayern 23,9.
Hier Bayern 23,9 mit dem Playlist-Check.
Bela B, du bist heute bei uns im Studio. Herzlich willkommen.
Hi.
Ja, also du weißt wahrscheinlich, wie es läuft. Wir spielen jetzt ein paar Songs vor und du musst uns sagen, wie die Playlist heißen könnte, in der diese Songs vorkommen.
Alles klar, ich bin gespannt.
Jetzt geht's los mit Around the World
von Daft Punk. Viel Spaß!
Das war Around the World
von Daft Punk. Hast du schon eine Idee, in welche
Richtung es geht, Bela? Ja,
in eine Daft Punk-Richtung wäre es eine Daft Punk-Punk.
Okay, okay, schon gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen mal weiter mit Song 2.
Hier ist Someone Like You von Adele.
Bitte schön. Sagen wir machen mal weiter mit Song zwei, hier ist Someone Like You von Adele, bitteschön. Someone like you, I wish nothing but the best for you to, don't forgive me, I'll be... Das läuft viel länger, warum lässt du das viel länger laufen als im Round the World? Das ist ein guter Song, ist einfach ein guter Song. Ja, weiß ich nicht, das ist jetzt wirklich... Das war Someone Like You von Adela. Bela, klingelt es bei dir? Nee, jetzt habe ich wirklich tausend Fragezeichen. Es hat für mich gar keine innere Struktur mehr. Ich bin raus. Alles klar, da würde ich sagen. Kommen wir jetzt zu unserem letzten Song. Und es ist Bubbly von Katie Malour. Bitteschön. There are nine million bicycles in Beijing. Oh, da haben wir, Entschuldigung, da ist ein System, oh, da haben wir, Bela, vergiss den Song, das war ein kleiner, ähm, nee, wir hören jetzt den richtigen Song nochmal, Entschuldigung, Bela, vergiss den mal gerade. Schwer zu vergessen ist gerade ein anderer Katie-Melewa-Song. Nee, Entschuldigung. Mal mal ohne Interpret. Jetzt kommt Bubbly. Okay. Bubbly. Ist das nicht dieser ... Bubbly? Ich kenne Bubbly. Bubbly. Ah, okay. Ja, ja, ja. So, das war unsere What's the Playlist. Das war sehr leise. Und das war nicht die Radio-Edit, sondern das war die Self-Conscious-Edit. Die This is my first song-Edit. Alles klar, wir haben jetzt alle drei Songs gehört. Bdb, wie heißt die Playlist? Je näher du an dem tatsächlichen Titel dran bist, desto mehr Punkte kriegst du. Forgettable Pop Songs. Deine Antwort ist Forgettable Pop Songs und diese Antwort ist Falt. Die richtige Antwort wäre Workout gewesen. Deswegen tut mir leid, Biller B, leider kein Preis für dich. Someone like you, I wish nothing. Aber warum? Warum sollte man denn ... Naja, aber ... Warum holt man sich den Ball der Fang? Ja, aber das motiviert dich doch, wenn jemand mit dir Schluss macht, sagst du, okay, jetzt trainiere ich, jetzt komme ich in die beste Form meines Lebens. Vielleicht ist das so eine Art emotionales Push. Aber harder, better, faster, stronger, higher, stronger. Faster. Das ist doch der Workout-Song. Ja, ja, ich sehe es doch. Ich verstehe schon, was du meinst. Und da guckt er mich mit grossen Augen an und sagt, ob es okay für mich ist. Der, wo alles an ihm schon sagt, der ist froh, wenn er hier nicht angesprochen wird und seine Übungen, seine Correctives machen kann. Alles an mir sagt ja, ich spreche mich nicht an. So, und dann fragt er mich mit grossen Augen, ob Harder, Better, Faster, Stronger ein okayer Workout-Song für mich ist. Ist aber für mich auch direkt wieder ein Neuzugang in unsere Prankshow. Wie lange würde es dauern? Gleiche Situation, du kommst in diesen Raum, der sagt, okay, du hast einen coolen Workout-Song, also klar, Playlist für dich, okay, wollen wir umstellen? Wunderbar, Wunderbar und dann nächster Song, blau wie der Enzian, Heino, einfach irgendwie sowas und dann einfach draufhalten. Ich glaube, das ist schon eine geile Reaktion und dann natürlich die Frage, wie lange würde es dauern, unsere alte Prankshow, der Timer läuft und bis man es anspricht. Bis man es anspricht und in dem Moment, in dem man anspricht, kriegt der Euro in Höhe der verstrichenen Minuten. Und dann kriegt er halt vier Euro und dann fre er sich vielleicht. Aber müsste man nicht belohnen, Leute belohnen, die sofort sagen, so geht es nicht oder was ist der Lohn? Okay, du meinst, er startet bei hundert Euro und verliert pro Minute ein Euro? Genau, hundert minus n. Okay, hundert minus t eins, die verstrichene Zeit, gleich n, verstehe. Gleich n Preisgeld. Okay, nee, finde ich auch gut. Wie lange würde es dauern, man startet immer, aber auch nicht. Tausend minus N. Tausend, aber dann zwei Euro pro Sekunde fallen weg. Tausend Euro und dann pro Sekunde. Tausend minus N durch zwei. Ja. Wurzel aus tausend. Warum ist immer die Hälfte der Sendung die Erklärung von diesem verdammten Timersystem? Das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Warum ist die Sendung wieder Year-Wir-In-Song-Contest? Man dachte, es wäre sehr klar, wie das hier funktioniert. Und die andere Hälfte ist, oh, es ist das Gegenteil von dem, was ich da... Und jeder ungerade Kandidat kriegt nochmal einen Bonus von 0,1 pro Minute steigert. Und dann gibt es noch die Big Five bei Deutschland automatisch im Finale. So, naja, ich finde es gut, jedenfalls wenn Leute belo belot werden, die direkt Dinge sagen. Und ich hätte verloren, nicht viel Geld bekommen, weil bei Adele hätte ich dann schon die rote Karte zeigen müssen. Aber wie ist es dann, wenn jemand jetzt reinkommt in diesen Raum und selber Kopfhörer trägt? Kann man das dann irgendwie synchronisieren oder muss man das dann vom Tempo anpassen? Einmal hat jemand vergessen, seine Playlist zu entkoppeln und ist dann mit seinem Handy hochgelaufen. Und das war nicht nur nervig, weil es immer wieder aufgehört hat, dass die Musik, dass Adele, someone like to you. Und dann plötzlich hört man so, du Ronny, ich habe nochmal kurz angerufen. Ja, exakt, wie das kam. Wirklich die Sprachnachricht, man hat ihn nicht gehört, aber die Frau, mit der er telefoniert, hat man gehört. Das ist ja perfekt! Und das ist ihm aber schnell aufgefallen, das ist ihm sehr schnell aufgefallen, ich hab nur so, hey, gehört, und dann war so ein, nee, ich hör dich, nee, ich hör dich, nee, ich hör dich, und dann war es auch. Und an dem Rhythmus, nee, ich hör dich, eins, nee, ich hör dich, zwei, nee, ich hör dich zwei, nee, ich hör dich drei.
Und das, dann hat er sie offensichtlich nicht gehört, das war sehr leicht zu deduzieren und hat dann aufgehört, hat wahrscheinlich das Handy nochmal entpoppelt. Das ist ja grandios.
Ja, diese Bluetooth-Anlage ist wirklich eine Falle einfach. Das ist ja eine soziale Falle.
Das ist eine soziale Falle.
Aber ich fand auch nicht schlecht, dass meine Camouflage-Hip-Hop-Playlist nicht daran gemacht hat, weil ich das machen wollte mal und auch technisch interessiert war. Ich finde es so gut, dass du einfach nur, damit du es mal gemacht hast, ohne dass der Inhalt sich ändert, einfach dieselbe Playlist nochmal. Und dann war ich fertig und dann waren inzwischen noch mehr Leute da und so. Und dann habe ich mich umgedreht und gesagt, ich mache meine Musik dann jetzt aus,
ihr könnt ja gucken, was ihr anmacht,
habe meine Hip-Hop-Playlist
ausgemacht und habe mich dann
aufgeregt, diese normale,
willkürliche Place, die da immer läuft und es ist
quasi der gleiche Song, lief
einfach weiter und alle haben sich
gefragt, ach, das war deine Musik,
weil es ist genau das, was hier immer eh
schon läuft und nicht, war das auch irgendwie lustig, weil es ist genau das, was hier immer eh schon läuft.
Und ich war das auch irgendwie lustig, weil man, ich habe kein musikalisches Selbstbewusstsein, aber auch weil meine Musikrechnung, alles was ich mag, finden alle immer so uncool.
Aber momentan, also wenn du jetzt dein Gerät entkoppelst, läuft dann automatisch die normale Playlist weiter oder ist dann stille?
Es ist erst mal stille.
Und dann muss jemand extra wieder aufstehen und die normale Playlist anmachen? Genau. Dann muss man auf Radio klicken und dann anmachen. Geht schon. Das ist alles sehr schnell machbar. Aber es ist natürlich auch, wenn da Leute Sport machen und schniefen und so, will man ja keine Stille haben. Also du willst ja keine Stille im Fitnessstudio haben. Du willst ja, das geht ja nicht. Und das hat mich sehr genervt bei diesem Adele-Ding, aber das fand ich echt interessant, weil irgendwie, entweder wirft er Daft Punk mit Adele in eine sehr enge kleine Gruppe und weil er hat dann ja nicht noch mal mich angucken wollen und noch mal, bei Adele war keine Diskussion. Hätte ich mich auch gefragt, was wenn erst Adele gewesen wäre. Ja. Hätte er mich dann auch gefragt, ob das okay ist, weil da hätte ich wahrscheinlich nein gesagt. Hätte ich nicht Nein gesagt. Falls du gerade zuhörst und dir diese Geschichte sehr bekannt vorkommt, dann melde dich, wir laden dich gerne ein in die nächste Folge, um solche Dinge mal wirklich zu klären, weil ich glaube, es gibt viele Leute, die ganz anders über die Situation wahrscheinlich denken, wie du in dem Moment, und ich würde gerne auch mal die andere Seite hören. Ja, es gibt mir häufig so. Die extrovertiertere Version, wo, es gibt viele Dinge im Alltag, wo ich mir denke, wow, das hätte ich sowas von niemals gemacht, so, aber die das einfach machen und einfach mal die andere Seite sehen. Also, falls ihr anders seid als wir, meldet euch. Und falls ihr der Typ seid mit Adele, der Adele-Freund, ich liebe Adele, das ist ja nicht, Workout würde ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt erwähnen. Da bin ich eher ... Was bist du denn beim Workout?
Naja, also da bin ich schon so ein ...
Podcast.
Der Rod Stewart-Podcast.
So ein schönes Trainingsfolge 28. Das gebe ich mir dann schon, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe auch immer einen Podcast gehört beim Trainieren, was ein bisschen merkwürdig ist, weil das ja jetzt einem nicht die nötige Energie gibt, an seine Grenzen und darüber hinaus zu gehen, sondern eher dafür sorgt, dass man versucht, möglichst konzentriert zuzuhören. Ja, das stimmt. Aber in der Zeit, in der ich gelaufen bin, war es immer so, ich wollte mich möglichst viel ablenken. Deswegen bin ich aber auch nachts gerne gelaufen. Konterintuitiverweise. Weil man da so viel sieht. Weil da ist man notwendigerweise in Gedanken. Da muss man irgendwann vergessen, dass man gerade läuft, weil das ist alles stockdunker. Und ja auch der Schmerz, weil du ständig gegen irgendwas läufst, betäubt dich. Und deswegen musst du in deinem Kopf über irgendwas nachdenken. Hast du viele Morde gesehen? Das steht mir nachts. Ja, also ich wurde einmal fast ermordet und ich habe auch gemordet und habe aber auch Morde im Gange gesehen tatsächlich. Also auch das Verscharren von Leichen, das passiert nachts, das muss ja irgendwo passieren. Und die Leute kommen an und man grüsst sich und ich bin zu schnell. Also die laufen mir hinterher mit ihrer Kettensäge, aber ich bin flink und die meisten versuchen gar nicht hinterher zu laufen, sondern akzeptieren, dass ich dann jetzt eben Augenzeuge bin. Nacht ist viel los, ne? Ja, oder wenig. Nacht ist viel oder wenig los, ne? Kommt auf die Stadt an. Es gibt Städte, die niemals schlafen, es gibt auch Städte, die immer schlafen. Wer schläft immer? Nürnberg, glaube ich. Ja, Nürnberg ist so eine, die Stadt, die immer schläft. Gute Träume. Berlin ist eine Stadt, die spät zu Bett geht, aber dafür auch sehr früh aufsteht. Muss man auch sagen. Aber einen unruhigen Schlaf auch. Berlin schläft unruhig. Musst du ja machen, wenn du so tust, als würdest du schlafen, musst du immer diese Zuckungen einbauen, damit es realistischer ist. Das ist die hohe Kunst des Schlafensstellens. Glaubst du, du kannst dich besser schlafen stellen als ich? Ne, ich bin sehr schlecht darin. Ja? Ja. Obwohl ich behaupte, dass ich gut beobachte, was Schlafen schlafender ausmacht. Ein gleichmässiger Atem, sich nicht zu bewegen, solche Dinge, ab und zu mal so zu zucken. Ja, da habe ich schon eine gewisse Beobachtungsgabe. Sneezen. Ich war kurz davor, einen lustigen Traum nachzuerzählen, dann dachte ich mir, nee, das mache ich nicht, möchte nicht mehr. Ich möchte es in anderen Podcasts auch nicht hören, wenn Treuen nacherzählt werden. Das ist jetzt vorbei, das haben wir vielleicht mal hier gemacht. Wir sind da jetzt weiter. Ja, wir haben alles schon erzählt. Und es ist auch manchmal so, manchmal kriegen wir auch Nachrichten. Dinge aber auch einfach, ja man kann immer so viel erfinden, auch bei Träumen, finde ich. Ja, also manchmal kriegst du Nachrichten, wo es heißt so, oh ich habe gestern von dir geträumt, dass du irgendwie auf einem Elefanten geritten bist, das gegen ein Nilpferd gekämpft hat. Und ich habe mir, okay, cool. Ich habe gestern von Adele geträumt. Passiert. Also ich will mich jetzt nicht mit Adele vergleichen, aber wenn du halt den Podcast hörst oder so, dann träumt man halt davon. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie man darauf reagieren soll.
Kämpfende Nilpferde nicht mit Adele vergleichen.
Nein, das auf gar keinen Fall.
Sie würde gewinnen.
Adele gegen den Nilpferd?
Kommt drauf an, in welchem Kontext.
In jedem Kontext würde sie gewinnen.
Capoeira, sie würde gewinnen. Kommt drauf an, in welchem Kontext. In einem Gesangskontest? In jedem Kontext würde sie gewinnen. Capoeira, sie würde gewinnen. Definitiv. Nilpferd ist kein schwerer Gegner. Du denkst immer, oh, gross und schwer. Ist sie das gefährlichste Tier der Welt? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Die Mücke ist das gefährlichste Tier der Welt. Ich hasse das, ich hasse dich. Ich hasse Leute, die mitTwist. Ja, ja, es ist wirklich so, man denkt es nicht, aber so ist es. Nee, ich glaube, der hatte keine Chance gegen die Päd. Aber das kann ja ein Traum von euch entscheiden. Das muss man ein Traum, ein Traumer von euch. Ja, versucht mal aktiv, mal an die luziden Traumer da draußen, die aktiv Dinge im Traum geschehen lassen können. Handelt das doch mal aus. Ich hätte zwei verschiedene Freunde, die unterschiedlich träumen. So, das wird noch wichtig. Der eine kann nämlich luzid träumen. Und der andere hatte schon mal einen Sextraum mit mir. Und ist ein heterosexueller Mann und hatte einen Sextraum mit mir. Und das wäre natürlich viel lustiger, wenn er derjenige gewesen wäre, der Lucie träumt. Weil dann könnte man sagen, Moment mal, du hast mir doch mal vor zwei Monaten erzählt, dass du Lucie träumst und du entscheiden kannst, was du machst. Und dann, ach so, das wäre lustig. Aber so ist es nicht. So ist es nicht. Aber manchmal ist die Realität nicht so, wie man sich das bringt. Der gedachte Gag heute bei uns. Das war die Rubrik. Wir liefern nur die Puzzlesteine. Ihr müsst das schon noch selber zusammenbauen. Wir erzählen hier, kein Quatsch, wir erfinden hier keine Gags. Wir erzählen die Realität nach, wie sie ist. Manchmal nicht so lustig. Ihr könnt das ja zusammenbauen und könnt es lustig nacherzählen. In eurem Freundeskreis könnt ihr dann doch diesen Gag mal machen. Ja. Aber ja, verrücktes Thema auf jeden Fall. Ich weiß auch nicht, was da von Humbug ist. Ich habe nur mal von so einem Skateboarder gehört, der irgendwie schwer gestürzt ist und Beine gebrochen hat oder so und in der Zeit aber weiter trainieren wollte und deswegen luzides Träumen gelernt hat, um im Traum weiter Skateboarden zu können. Und nach seiner Aussage hat das auch was gebracht. Er war danach ein besserer Skateboarder, obwohl er tatsächlich nie Skateboard gefahren ist. War halt sehr unausgeschlafen. War sehr müder, besserer Skateboarder. Was soll ich denn über diese Geschichte denken? Sehr fantastisch, wenn man das kann. Aber auch Unsinn, weil er muss ja nicht nur, also wenn man sich den, erst mal den luziden normalen Traum in seiner Ausgangssituation vorstellt, ist er einfach so eine leere, weisse Matrix, oder nicht? Du hast ja erst mal jetzt keine Schwerkraft. Das heißt, er muss ja nicht nur sich den Skatepark vorstellen, er muss sich ja auch noch die Schwerkraft vorstellen. Du fängst schon so in so einer Startzone an, in so einer Bäckerei oder sowas und in der Ecke. Nicht Sandkastenprinzip. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Du kriegst eine Basis und dann musst du irgendwie auswählen und dann kannst du Dinge verändern oder so. Okay. Aber es gibt bestimmt auch viele tolle Serien, die sich mit dem Thema beschäftigen oder Filme auch. Vielleicht eine kleine Serienempfehlung am Ende? Ich habe diese Woche sehr genossen auf Apple-TV Severance. Gut, da habe ich auch schon viel von gehört. Freue ich mich drauf. Könnt ihr gerne angucken. Ich möchte euch etwas Late to the Party, möchte euch Band of Brothers empfehlen. Habe ich jetzt endlich mal geguckt. Es ist ein alter Klassiker. Aber ich glaube, viele von euch haben das vielleicht nicht gesehen, weil viele von euch in unserem Alter sind und man kann ja nicht alles gesehen haben, was vor unserer Zeit alles schon tolles rauskam, von daher empfehle ich, muss auch nicht peinlich sein, Band of Brothers macht sehr viel Spaß zu gucken. Es gibt ein 20-jähriges Jubiläum, auch mit einem extra Podcast dazu, wo jede einzelne Folge ist eine zehnteilige Miniserie, auch nochmal kommentiert wird, schaut es euch an, ansonsten habt eine schöne Woche.
Habt eine schöne Woche, macht's gut.
Haut rein, macht's gut, wir heben ab, in die Luft!